what we see is a very disturbing trend
in American law enforcement we're seeing
innocent citizens shot and killed on
drug raids we are seeing the wrong house
hit on a drug raid we are seeing
high-powered weapons in the hands of
untrained and therefore unskilled police
officers we're seeing scared cops who've
been made to believe that you know that
they are going after the enemy that is
the mindset who are much more likely to
engage in impulsive behavior and I think
the way it's supposed to be it's just
not I don't blame the agents I don't
even blame the heads of the agencies I
blame us whose laws are we talking about
we're really talking about the people's
laws and and if we're not satisfied with
the laws that that our federal
government is enforcing then we really
need to take a look at what our
responsibility is why have we let this
go so long over a hundred million people
have smoked marijuana at least once we
got an omission I think from the
incumbent president we had one from the
previous president who although he
didn't inhale admitted to putting it to
his mouth and breaking the law and I
think it's just time for us to recognize
that we're that were just being very
very foolish and we're spending huge
sums of money on on Drug Enforcement in
general but but on marijuana in
particular
leap takes the view that prohibition
doesn't work never has never will that
the drug war has caused more harm than
good
that if we really want to deal with the
nation's drug quandary or problem that
we will regulate the drug we will
legalize it so that we can regulate it
and then we can control it we can't do
that otherwise we have spent one
trillion dollars prosecuting the drug
war since Richard Nixon declared war on
drugs in 1971 another 69 billion dollars
a year down the rat hole and what do we
have to show for it drugs are more
readily available today at lower prices
and higher levels of potency than in the
history of the drug war so the
longest-running war in the history of
the United States armed conflict I dare
say has been an abysmal failure I
characterize it as the most destructive
and damning social policy since slavery
after my book came out I was talking
with a police chief who had read the
drug chapter and I said okay let me have
it because I know you're gonna disagree
with me and he said I agree with
everything you're saying I said my gosh
can I quote you and he asked well what
do you been smoking he says no you can't
quote me here's a new major city police
chief and I by the way talked to an
awful lot of police chiefs and other
elected officials who whisper their
support for the legalization approach
but who are for a variety of reasons
most of which are obvious reluctant or
fearful to speak out but I asked this
guy as we were comparing notes over our
drug of choice in the bar afterwards how
many people under the influence of
marijuana turned violent on you and I
was talking about marijuana and any
other drug most particularly beer or
wine or distilled spirits
how many have turned violent on you in
your career as a cop
none
I've asked that question over and over
and over in the last two or three years
on book tour and speaking engagements
and so forth not one police officer not
one has said I remember I had this
pothead who you know someone on me and I
had to do this and so on and so forth
then I'll ask how about drunks how about
people under the influence of alcohol
and they and it's laughable but what
five minutes ago ten minutes ago come on
you work almost any beat in almost any
city in this country you're going to be
dealing with belligerent drunks and and
and and some of them become extremely
violent and some of them become
extremely dangerous to the safety of
police officer not to mention the other
folks around them or themselves so one
of the things that's very clear is this
dichotomy between a drug that does not
produce that behavior demonstrably does
not produce that behavior in fact sort
of the opposite behavior and a drug that
does the drug that does produce more
belligerents more violence more health
problems and financial problems for our
country more family and community
problems for our country then all other
drugs combined is legal so there's
something wrong with that picture
Hempfest in seattle is is the largest
gathering i think in the world certainly
in north america of marijuana advocates
the police officers working it enjoy it
the feedback that I got from my cops
after that my first year in Seattle was
that's great duty now you know I don't
know whether they were you know
experiencing secondhand highs or just
let it was but if we see somebody light
up we can't arrest them and the emphasis
on can not will on the other side the
organizer services are announcing to the
crowd you know you cannot break the law
while you're here well of course there
is widespread law breaking going on at
Hempfest you don't put tens of thousands
of marijuana users together without a
certain percentage of them smoking
marijuana
the officers exercise discretion
marijuana in the City of Seattle is now
the lowest enforcement
the result of a citizen initiative i-75
and he was 2003 after I retired and that
was a message from the community to the
police department in the prosecutor's
office that we we believe that simple
adult possession of marijuana ought to
be the lowest enforcement priority lower
indeed than jaywalking and it is people
have this longing for the old days and
and there's a tendency to romanticize
that there's no question about that this
this idea that the beat cop was your
friend the because somebody could turn
to if you are lost or afraid or we're
experiencing problems in your own home
or in your neighborhood and and it was
you know there are a lot of people who
tell some pretty inspiring stories about
what the police did for them many many
years ago but what we've been doing
since the declaration of the war on
drugs of course is is pitting the police
against young people pitying the police
against people of color wildly
disproportionate numbers of whom are
going to prison behind simple possession
cases there they are there are losing
their their federal financing for their
education they're losing subsidized
housing in some cases they are you know
developing that that permanent record
that lifelong record possibly the result
of the possession of a joint commit the
crime of rape commit the crime murder be
convicted be sentenced serve time get
back out you go right back into public
housing you can you can get that that
federal financing of your education but
you can't if you're if you're caught
with any amount of any illegal drug who
opposes an end to the drug war well the
drug warriors certainly do because we
have seen huge sums of money coming to
local jurisdictions in in in the form of
grants and assistance in the creation of
task forces seized in forfeited assets
which is an entirely different story
well it's not a different story but it's
a whole nother story
all of this feeding this this this this
beast this incredible economic system
and I you know speaking personally I
believed
this body is mine that it is sovereign I
believe in taking care of it but if I
didn't it would still be my right to
inject and gesture inhale anything into
this body that I chose and that would
include a bullet that's that's my
personal belief about individual liberty
at the same time I recognize with with
equal force equal power that if what I
put into my body causes me to drive
impaired furnish to a kid or abuse a
spouse or a child or commit a bank
robbery that I need to pay a painful
price for what I've done so I think a
whole lot of people can agree that it is
it is possible to create laws that say
we're gonna respect you as an individual
once you once you venture out or perhaps
within the confines of your own home you
commit criminal acts that hurt other
people
stand by because you're gonna pay for it
and that III think that resonates with
an awful lot of people who haven't
really thought through certain of the
implications of the drug war society
friends neighbors let's think about what
we're doing arresting people over and
over and over again and not achieving a
safer Street a cleaner Street a more
healthy environment for our kids or for
our business owners or for anyone else
you